All right, welcome to today's Zoom call.
It is the 15th of June 2022 reminder again,
to make sure you look up your questions on our blog
if you have questions if you need them answered
before the Zoom call comes along.
And if you haven't joined the membership site,
the patient membership site, please do so.
Should everybody should have received
a invite to it.
If some reason you can't find your invite,
go to your main email that you have used
to communicate with the clinic,
because it's based upon your email.
And search in Policotters Clinic,
or membership to find it,
where you could email me at in Policotters Clinic
and I'll resend it.
We've only had a few people that had difficulty getting on
some strange reason.
Everybody's gone up, that's asked.
That's where you ask your questions
and the easiest way to ask questions is through their place.
We'll only had a few questions come in.
So let's talk about them.
This is the least amount of questions
that we had said in a couple of years.
So everybody must be doing well.
I hope we pray for that.
And everybody must be getting the fighting their answers.
So here's a great question.
Are the greens and SEAC in the pill form
just as good as the liquid form?
Okay, so the SEAC is considered a T.
So SEAC was developed by the,
I think it's the Ojibwe Indians
in northern United States and Canada
to use for treatment for serious disease
and that it was used on people that had a diagnosis
with cancer, with good results, with many of them.
Nothing is a cure for cancer.
We do understand that.
So you're doing everything you possibly can
to help your body fight the disease like any other disease.
But SEAC was that herb in a tincture type form
that was then put in a liquid and it was sipped.
And for some reason, and it doesn't mean
that taking a dried herbal formula of the same herbs
won't work just as well from a physiological standpoint.
I can't see how it would work any different.
But in its original form, it was in a liquid form
but it was supposed to be sipped slowly.
If that's the only reason it,
from a physiological standpoint, maybe was that you're not,
you're absorbing it more slowly over time.
Well, good to say, could I just take the pills,
let's split out during the day?
We have made it just as much sense.
I don't know.
For me, it's a lot easier to take pills.
Sometimes than it is to make a shake.
Now, if I'm at work, I make shakes almost daily at work.
It's really easy to throw the blender and make a greens shake
and that does kind of push me to add other things to it
that are going to be beneficial for me.
And so I do prefer the shake at different times.
But I also use the greens first capsules at home
that if I'm busy, I don't make shakes as often as at home
that I do at work.
And so it's easier for me to take the capsules.
That's certainly a whole lot easier
to take capsules when you're traveling.
So I get that.
So for the greens for sure,
I don't think it makes any difference
whether you're taking the capsules
or you're making it a shake.
I don't think the absorption is any different
in any way from a physiological standpoint.
SCAC, it's just that traditional way of taking it
was sipping it like a tea.
But I don't know that there really be any physiological difference
to it if you're taking the same herbs.
Can I open the foot detox machine and clean it by sanding it?
I'd say no, don't do that.
Or could I spray the inside with a cleaner?
No, go to that.
In your manual, there's a way to clean the ion foot bath.
Also, there's a video on the membership site
on how to clean the ion foot bath.
We made a video on a two.
It's on the everything right, it's on the right page.
So look at that.
So you use maryotic acid to clean your foot bath machine
and you should do that on a regular basis.
I don't know of anybody that cleans at each time,
but if you clean it once a month or something,
you're gonna help prolong the life of it.
Listen, we've had people that have used it
never ever cleaned the thing
if they get 120 uses on of it.
The ion pro wave does the little apparatus of the ion pro wave
technically only is supposed to last about 80 sessions.
We've had people get a lot more than that,
even not cleaning it.
But I would think that if you do clean it,
you are going to get more sessions on it.
So, but clean it the way they recommend.
Oh, the cost of replacing it, I think it's like 120 bucks.
So we have them on our website for the,
I think it's around 120, 130, 140 bucks, something like that.
Coming up to my fifth out of sixth chemo infusions,
how do I decide if I stop chemo after the sixth time
or this continue with alternative therapies?
How do I decide that?
This is probably one of the most common questions
that I get in personal calls.
And this is a question that I just,
if we, I say, I feel like, you know,
I say it so often that I ended up making a video
at several posts a month because I did.
So look at that.
I can't legally tell you these things.
I can't tell you whether you should stop chemo
or you should do chemo or not do chemo.
That gets into medical conferencing
that gets into giving you medical advice
and I'm not a licensed medical doctor
or I'm not treated cancer.
So the state board already does not like me at all.
Does not like me at all.
Does not like that I'm trying to help people
with a cancer diagnosis.
Does not like that I'm not an oncologist pushing chemo.
Does not like the color of my hair probably.
So I have to be really careful out of that.
Besides the fact that even if I was licensed
and couldn't tell you these things,
I think that's wrong to do so.
Chemo, you can't argue with the fact
that chemo has saved people's lives and can kill cancer.
But you also can't argue with the fact
that many people maybe have met their demise
because of chemo.
So how am I to say that chemo is good for a person
or bad for a person, I can't say that.
So as many as many as nobody
people ask me this question,
I have to give them the same answer.
I can't legally nor can I ethically answer that question.
You have to make that decision
and that's where I refer back to having a relationship
with God where you could be prayed about
and feeling peace about the decision you make
so that you know that it's the right decision for you
that you have peace about it regardless
of what the outcome is because that's be honest.
You could do chemo and the chemo could kill you
or you could not do chemo
and because you didn't do chemo,
you ended up passing away because the cancer killed you
and how you supposed to know that, you know?
Well, you're taking your oncologist's advice
because the practice of medicine in the United States
have basically deemed a medical doctor
who's following standards of care
which was written by the pharmaceutical company
to be somewhat God-like
and as long as you do everything that this God-like oncologist
tells you to do, then you're going to be okay
but then if you're not okay,
well, then they don't take any responsibility.
Well, we did everything we could
and you passed away but we tried our best,
we did everything we could
but then if you chose not to do standards of care,
well, then you're somehow a communist or something
and should be labeled as such.
It's just really sad the whole thing
that we deal with in this country
and step off by soapbox but we get complaints
from the state board against us.
We're constantly being hounded for any little thing
we say wrong that could constitute
that we're practicing medicine
and all we're trying to do
is give people advice to basically consult God
about the decisions that they make in healthcare
and everything not putting the practice of medicine
of any kind, even alternative medicine
in the place of God.
So I wish I could help answer this question
but I think the proper answer
and the ethical answer to this question
is what I've stated
is that you really need to seek advice
from your heavenly father what's gonna be best for you
because only he knows.
And that's why we say over and over again
our website says over and over again,
we're here to support you whatever decision you make.
We're not here to judge you because you did chemo
or we're not here to judge you
because you didn't do chemo.
We're here to just support you no matter what you do
and give you as much nutritional support
and health support to build up your immune system
and prayer support.
And that's what our purpose is here for you.
So I know that people struggle with this question
probably more than anything else.
And I know some people probably get really mad at me
because I just don't flat out give them an answer
like an oncologist would,
but he has no fear of saying you need to do chemo
because honestly if he says anything other than that
he could get in trouble.
I was just talking to another doctor
that I know a medical doctor graduate from medical school
doesn't practice medicine anymore.
But this person said that there's someone they know
who is practicing medicine in the state of Minnesota
and in the emergency room there was a very ill patient
I can't remember if they had liver cancer
but they had some sort of cancer.
I think it was liver cancer.
And this practicing physician said to this patient
with liver cancer, well, maybe you need to stop eating
cookie and cookies.
Maybe that would be the best thing for you.
And there was another physician in the room
and that other physician wrote up this physician
and now this person has to go in front of the board
and may lose their license
to recommend that they stop eating cake and cookies
to help improve their liver cancer.
It is insane and it is becoming more and more insane.
And so I had a question posed to me
in the Zoom call a couple of weeks ago,
hey, how could we best pray for you?
That would be the number one prayer
that I would request from our patients
is that you pray for our protection from the powers
that be, hey, Satan does not want us doing what we're doing.
Satan does not want us helping people,
does not want us giving advice, does not want us praying
for people, does not want us serving people
to try to build their immune system
and build their God-given human defense system
against disease.
And he has constantly attacked us by the state board
and the attorney general is off
and we're constantly being attacked and abused.
And we're just not gonna stop trying to help people
and even if I have to do it in jail.
So, but I ask that you just keep us in your prayers that way.
So it's not only for that reason
that I can't answer this question,
but I've never answered this question
in the way that most people want me to,
they want me to give them an answer
of what they should do.
And I get it and I understand it.
But I hope you understand our position of that too.
Question came in, I just went to the dentist this morning
for my annual cleaning and they discovered
I too lived notes under my chin are both swollen
and asked if I had been sick.
I have not, but I'm wondering why they would be swollen.
They recommended I tell my doctor
if that doesn't go away in three weeks
because they're aware of my cancer diagnosis.
What are you if you have any input?
So yes, you can have swollen lip nodes for multiple reasons.
You can have a swollen lip node.
So remember what lip nodes do.
So lip nodes are little nodules
along the chain of a lip vessel.
So a lip vessel is an open ended vessel, open ended capillary.
They give it as a storm sewer.
Like you have a storm sewer on your street
if you live in the city.
So heavy rain comes all the water runs down
your sidewalk down into the street, into the storm sewer.
Well, where does that drain then?
That drains down into sewer system and goes somewhere.
I don't know where a storm sewer goes,
maybe to the river, but in your body
you have these open ended capillaries
just like the storm sewer.
So if you have 80 reason for inflammation anywhere
that inflammation will go into the open ended capillary.
This is how you get rid of dead cells.
This is how you get rid of dead tissue.
This is how you get rid of metabolic waste from cells
drain into the, are dumped into the extra cellular space,
the space around the cell.
And then we'll make their way through motion,
through muscle contraction into these open ended vessels
called lymph vessels.
And then they will carry, there's no part
that pumps lymph, but through your muscle contraction,
through motion and through gravity,
that lymph, what's in the lymph vessel,
which is basically waste and swelling
will travel through the lymph vessel,
ultimately back to the vein,
which will then carry it basically
through the blood supply and your liver
will pull it out and detoxify.
That's how you get chemicals out of your body,
like toxins out of your body go into the lymph system
and out into the vein.
And then through your liver detox pathways
and dumped into your small intestine,
go through your colon and dumped into the toilet.
That's how you get rid of things in your body.
But along the course of this lymph vessel,
you have these little nodes and these little nodes
are concentrations of white blood cells
that will then kill anything
because this is going to be dumped,
this waste is going to be ultimately dumped
into the venous system and go into the arterial system
to be carried to the liver and to the kidneys,
to be ultimately deposited in the toilet.
And if it's full of infection bacteria,
you're basically going to spread bacteria
all over your body.
So you have these lymph nodes that have a concentration
of immune cells that will kill any bacteria
or viruses or parasites in that waste
that's being drained from the tissue.
So let's say I'm a dental abscess and an infection
and a tooth and all that infection is there
while that's going to drain into the lymph vessel
and we don't want to just cause an infection systemically.
So it goes into the lymph node and the lymph node
kills that infection before it goes into the venous system
and arterial system and make you all very sick.
So in the case of drainage of an infection,
that's the most common reason why a person would have
that inflamed and enlarged lymph node.
So lymph node, the enlarged and inflamed hypertrophy
get larger because there's an infection being killed
or a perceived infection.
So even if it's you have a lot of swelling
that's going through the lymph node or something like that,
that perceived infection could increase the size
of the lymph node and those typically increase sizes
are only for a period of time.
They're not going to stay that large.
Also, it can enlarge due to an allergy of some side too.
So anytime you add any type of cytokine reaction
for something else, you could get it enlarged lymph node.
So I would think number one would be an infection
that would be superior to where that lymph node is
that dreaded area of the lymph node possible
inflammatory reaction of some other kind,
maybe a histamine reaction or something like that too
could possibly increase the lymph node.
Those are the most common things.
A person with a cancer diagnosis,
having a large lymph node,
you're also concerned about is there the taster size?
Is there a metastasis to the lymph node?
Again, that would be more common in line with how that area
where the cancer is drains.
So if the person had had that cancer,
that's where you think about a large lymph node
under the jaw.
If they had breast cancer,
could be super clavicular lymph node
or a lymph node in the chest.
So you have to kind of discern that.
So I'd watch that if the lymph node is not painful at all
if it's enlarged and not painful at its hard,
that's typically textbook more in line
with the possibility of a metastasis,
if the lymph node is inflamed and it's painful to touch a little bit
off, I move it around, okay, it hurts.
That's much more in line with it being
in large form of infection.
Long answer to that, sorry about that.
Okay, during an overnight program,
is it normal for the true life to start beeping
and the LED to flash?
Yes, yep, that's normal,
but it's running different frequencies,
it's gonna make different sounds.
Next question, can one have tumor,
but no circulating tumor cells in the blood?
Yes, for sure.
So you will not always have circulating tumor cells
and that's why I'm not a big fan
of testing for circulating tumor cells.
Because circulating tumor cells are circulating
to the tissue, they're not just gonna stay in the blood.
So to test, if you have circulating tumor cells,
to me, doesn't really give you much information.
That's why people will argue,
why did my oncologist test for circulating tumor cells?
Well, my question would be,
why do you want to test for circulating tumor cells?
You just have to assume that you had circulating tumor cells,
but if you had a diagnosis of cancer,
you had circulated tumor cells at some point in time
and at different points in time,
why would you need to test for them?
So I would agree with an oncologist
that I don't see any need to test for those.
You're not always gonna have circulating tumor cells.
Next question, is there a lab besides the Navarro Clinic
that will perform the HCG urine cancer test?
No, there is not that I don't want to build them.
Sorry.
Next question, my calcium is high.
10.2, I just finished a 10 session radiation treatment.
My oncologist told me to eat less calcium,
but everything seems to have calcium,
even if my almond milk and some vegetables and fruits,
what should I do?
I would agree with your oncologist
in that you shouldn't be taking a lot of calcium,
but I wouldn't be concerned about eating foods
with that are high in calcium
and less you're eating a much dairy products,
which the calcium is not a good form of calcium.
You should be eating your vegetables,
which you don't have to worry about your calcium content
of that.
Typically, a high calcium in your blood
would refer to calcium spillage.
So it really has a very little or nothing
to do with consumption of calcium.
Even if you overdose on a really horrible source
of supplemental calcium like calcium carbonate,
which is in a lot of the cheapo vitamins out there,
it really wouldn't produce high blood levels of calcium
because your body has a buffering system.
So it will pull out the excess calcium.
And unfortunately, poor sources of calcium
like calcium carbonate can be deposited in your vessels
and cause arteriosporosis.
That's why I'm so against poor choices in supplementation
and using cheap supplements and garbage stuff out there
that's using elemental minerals.
And I have a video on choosing the right mineral product.
But that's another point.
Typically, high blood calcium suggests something that's going on.
Let's say the person has no diagnosis of cancer
and they have high blood calcium.
What would be the first thing you'd think of?
First thing you'd think of would be parathyroid disease.
Your parathyroid glands are located
according to their name, Dex2, the thyroid gland.
And what they do is they should create a hormone
that helps you get rid of calcium in your kidneys.
But when you have a parathyroid disease of some kind,
mainly it's usually it's parathyroid tumor.
You end up retaining calcium, too much calcium
from your kidneys and you end up with high blood calcium.
Well, the treatment for that is fairly simple.
You get that diagnosed and you remove the parathyroid glands
and you could live a very long life without that.
But high calcium can cause issues like arteriosporosis.
So you don't want to have high calcium.
If you have a diagnosis of cancer and you have high calcium,
that brings up the other point.
The second most common cause of high calcium
is because of a cancer diagnosis in a lidic metastasis.
So if you have metastasis to the bone,
it's almost always what's called lidic.
So if you have primary cancer to the bone,
it's very often a plastic disease.
What's the difference?
So a plastic disease means you have laydown of calcium.
So the bone gets larger.
You end up with a dodge will off the bone.
That's called a plastic disease.
So blastocytes and osteoblasts, particularly in bone,
are cells that build bone.
Osteoclasts break down bone.
Lytic terminology means the breakdown of.
So when cancer metastasizes from another cancer,
say breast cancer, prostate cancer,
the metastasizes to the bone, it's almost always
a lidic disease.
Meeting it involves osteoclasts, the breakdown of bone.
Well, where does that calcium go that's in the bone?
It gets pushed to the bone.
So you end up with high calcium levels in the blood.
10.2 is it overwhelmingly high compared
to some people that have a real issue.
But this is really why you did the radiation therapy.
I'm sure so.
I wouldn't worry to answer this question.
You did the treatment with the oncologist
to deal with the cause of the problem.
I personally wouldn't worry so much about my dietary calcium,
unless you're taking supplements that had a calcium in it.
In case this is helpful to others,
I had poorly managed chemo-induced peripheral neuropathy.
I had improvement with acupuncture after blood treatment.
That's great news.
Somebody asked that question.
I think a few weeks ago, could they do acupuncture?
I know it's been asked two dozen times
on our Zoom calls about using acupuncture
for neuropathy and acupuncture can be very, very helpful.
One caveat I would say to that is some people do acupuncture
and try it and it doesn't help at all.
My comment back is that you don't just,
you know, it's great that this person had success with one treatment,
but don't give up if it doesn't happen that fast.
So acupuncture is stimulating your body to heal itself.
It's not treating disease of any kind.
And sometimes it takes multiple sessions.
So just don't give up on acupuncture.
It could be very beneficial.
Regarding the Navarro test,
I appreciated that question because I went to their website last week
and they're not accepting any samples.
Yes, yes, we've been talking about that's very sad.
They're just overwhelmed.
Are there natural ways to reduce the size of a breast tumor?
Well, you know, everything we're doing is trying to do that.
So that's exactly what we're trying to accomplish.
I have read high, that high dose of vitamin C is made from glucose.
And camel camel is better,
more naturally derived source of vitamin C.
Are there high dose vitamin C options?
IV options that are not made for that are made from natural sources.
Really good question.
And that is that we have we have searched for that.
And we have not found that.
And that's one of the reasons why I'm not always that is vitamin C
doesn't test for a lot of IV vitamin C doesn't test for a lot of people
because it works using for test sources what they're using.
And I'm not saying that it's still not beneficial for people,
but it is a squirmic acid.
It isn't a whole food source because you can't get high dose of vitamin C in a whole food source.
So understand understand what I'm talking about.
So vitamin C like any other supplement I talked about vitamin E last week.
Vitamin C the same thing when it was first discovered.
They only had remember most these things were discovered in the 20s and 30s and 40s
was a level and quality of microscopy at that that they had at that time
is was really poor compared to what we have today.
So when vitamin C was discovered all they saw was the outer shell which is a squirmic acid.
So that is legally legally vitamin C is a squirmic acid.
So if you look up vitamin C you'll see a squirmic acid.
But in truth, no vitamin is just one thing.
It's a molecule of combination of molecules that work synergistically in nature.
And vitamin C is the same that whole food vitamin C has all these other synergistic cofactors that work with it.
It's not just a squirmic acid.
But from a legal standpoint, a squirmic acid is vitamin C.
So most vitamin C out there is going to be just a squirmic acid.
The problem with whole food vitamin C is it's typically very low dose.
And low dose of measurable a squirmic acid.
And there's no way that they could do that in a whole food source.
I totally agree that's a difficult thing with using IV nutrients is that they're not whole food.
Recently I had a CT scan without contrast due to the contrast shortage found out the board of the scan.
Wow, that's interesting.
I asked the radiation oncologist for a comparison to previous scan he ordered one via the radiologist.
Results in brief was cancer was stable yet one of my deal friends said to have a CT scan without contrast was useless without contrast to monitor progress.
I was surprised to hear that even though the radiologist didn't mention anything thoughts.
So I wouldn't say that it's useless, but it's not if you had a CT scan with contrast and now you're having a CT scan without contrast, you're not really measuring apples to apples.
Now you'd have to speak to a radiologist to get a more full understanding of that because that's not me.
But you it still is two different scans and it really partly depends upon that person's type of cancer and I don't have the answer to that for the types of cancer.
But some cancers it's it's fine to not use contrast to be able to visualize it some you need contrast to visualize it and that's would be a question for the oncologist, but that's a good question.
I have heard you on the circulated I just heard you a circulated tumor testing. I haven't hoping to check circulated to ourselves midway through the chemo protocol based on info from your book that says tax on specifically shrinks tumors but also can elevate circulated to ourselves.
I don't remember that part of my book must have anxiety to study. I was hoping to check circulated to ourselves current state to gauge how they're trending now.
I would be careful with that and for the same answer that I had above is that, you know, I would be and I don't know that there's any data on this, but I would question, let's say if you had a blood test at eight o'clock this morning, you had another one at four o'clock this afternoon, and you did that for about three or four days straight.
I would be willing to bet that your circulated tumor cell numbers would not be consistent. I think they would be up and down if they were if they showed I don't think that circulated to ourselves are released by by a existing cancer at any regular rate whatsoever.
There's any data that shows how regular that they're released. So if I quoted a study in the book about tax, all it was it was somebody else's work that I was quoting.
As I had normal circulated to a code before beginning to chemo, so you would be a great study on this. This would be I would love to see the results of this if you are going to choose to do that.
I'm thinking this might help decide if I continue chemo. I think that's a good thing. I think you're sticking really clearly there. So is there an existing test that will check circulated tumor cells. There's certain there are circulating tumor sound tests out there that are medical tests that you can have done.
There's nothing anything that we could run, but you may want to check with them. I don't know if your colleges will run these. I know you're this person that colleges is very friendly to try natural things. They may be able to run those.
Should I try SAC even if I didn't see it listed on my tree. Well, like always our way is not the highway. The only way. So we are not by way is the highway. So I'm saying I have a good way things all mixed up here. Sorry, but we are not the only way if you believe God is leading you to try something but by all means listen to him.
So if you want to try SAC that you go right ahead and try SAC. So that's your prerogative. I'm not anything against that.
My doctor thinks I've gotten out of all the two got no all the tumor with the black sand and are no working with microscopic disease. I'm about to apply application number 16.
The lived node is now feeling smaller and flatter any idea how many more applications paid isn't is decreasing and escarts are coming out faster.
No, but my thought is you just keep applied and tell nothing else comes out. It's just as far as you got all the tumor, but all you're dealing with microscopic disease. I'm sorry, but cancer is a microscopic disease.
It is one cell that is going to arrive in a rapid replication. So if you're pulling that out, you just keep going until it's done.
So don't stop until you get it all out. So congratulations, you are a great testimony to hard work and person clearance.
And I just you're just God is just really honoring that in your life, you know, I just so proud of you.
I just got some supplements from cutters clinic and have had a reaction to taking supplements. I feel nause and a little shaky. Do you do you have do work to work into taking them sometimes.
Yes, sometimes people are more sensitive to things than other people.
Some people can just take handfuls of supplements and have no problem. Some people have a little upset stomach. Maybe it has to do with the little not enough HCl in your stomach. Maybe it has to do with sensitivity to some of the capsule, the capsules themselves.
Everybody's a little bit different. So it's always good to start slow and work up. So let's say if something's recommended to take three times a day, you might want to take only one a day and work up to three times a day and do that at each one of your supplements that might be a lot better.
I want to try taking them with food that might work better too. So try those things. I think that's great.
That's great.
God, thank you. Yeah, you keep me posted that would be really great. So grab right.
My oncologist uses a signature I circulated to her. So that's interesting. That's good. No, so I'll write that down.
I enjoyed your interviews with Nathan Crane on the recent missing link documentary. Thank you. Are those available on our website.
You know, it's hard. I could ask Dustin.
Because I, I would these just recently published. I don't know because I mean, these were interviews that I did probably months ago when I do a lot of them. So I don't even know what he used them on.
So I will ask Dustin. We're trying to get any any interviews that I do up on our members site.
But Dustin said there are some legal things that we have to ask permission to do so. I have to do that. So I'll check into that and see if we can get that any other questions.
What do you recommend for nausea? So when I had really bad nausea.
It was a product from young livid. It was an essential oil that had generated it.
And it was called two person. I haven't sit in my car case. I get it any good nausea. We're going to have it in nausea for a while.
Or if I did, it's just past real quick. So I take anything.
There's also a polyopathic spray that we sell that's.
Remember who makes it. It's called not now nausea.
But make sure if you have nausea that you, if it's meant that we're, when you're getting nausea, if it's taking it, if you're getting nausea, if it takes supplements, make sure you eat a little bit.
Sometimes it's best just to keep a little bit. It's a food in your stomach.
It's not going to be beneficial.
But to me, when I had really bad nausea, using an essential oil, a ginger helped, using ginger, choose, can help.
I know I have several videos on nausea, and I know I have several blog posts on nausea.
So look those up on our website to search nausea. Here, you should find something.
Sorry, I can't remember the name of that one product that I have several months at home.
What happens if you retire? Well, you have to worry about me retiring. You have to worry about me.
I don't ever plan on retiring. But if something happens to me and I hit by a bus, well, then you know, hopefully my staff is going to continue on.
This clinic can continue with this.
Our mission because we all believe the same thing.
And that is that we, this is a colleague that we have.
And that's where I ask your prayers, everybody's prayers that we can continue this.
The way we're operating before the medical establishment tries to shut us down. That's what we need to be praying for.
So, these group sessions like this are the most protective for us.
And that is because these are just educational, this falls under the freedom of speech, which still exists in this country for, I don't know how long, but.
So, that's.
Okay, if you had to choose between I and foot bath and far and for Santa for detoxing.
For me, I would say disorder.
I have been doing something every day because it feels so good, but then have been not foot bathed as much.
I'm honest with everybody and I tell everybody this, when if they ask the question personally, I don't ever do I am pro waves.
And it's not because I don't believe in them or I don't like them. It's just I just don't take the time to do that.
That's just my personality. I can't sit in one place at any given time.
Well, Santa is sitting, but I do feel so much better when I do the sauna. So, I don't do the sauna in the summer, but in the winter, I do the sauna.
And it's, I think that, you know, if you are a sweater, you are sweating in the sauna, you are, you are literally taking so much pressure off your kidneys and your liver.
Remember, anything that goes through your liver is trying to detox, you have to go through the phase one phase two phase three pathways, then it has to get them to the small intestine.
Then it has to get all the way to the toilet before you reabsorb it.
And if you're sweating it out, you're using your skin as a detoxification portal.
And that is just taking so much pressure off your liver kidneys.
Thank you. Digi is the essential oil. Yes, it is. Thank you for that. That is the essential oil that I used to typically just would put a drop on my finger and put it in my mouth.
Maybe two or three drops. If my nausea was really bad and that seemed to help doesn't help everybody, but it helped me.
Good question here is working up a sweat outside at a hot sunny day just as good as a sauna. Yes.
If you're looking at a sauna as not the other possible benefits of far infrared, but simply as sweating and detoxifying through your skin and using your skin as a portal of detoxification and bypassing the liver and the kidneys like I just explained.
Then absolutely, that's why I go through the sauna in the summer because I garden and work outside all the time.
So that's just what I like to do. So I sweat like a, you know, poked hog outside. So I feel like I'm sort of just about every day what I'm outside doing that.
So absolutely, you're helping with detoxification through sweating.
Remind me of remedies for tonight's please. Is it a brain problem is so good for tonight is.
I don't know if I have a lot on my blog about tonight is we could pronounce it tonight is or tinnitus either way.
Because tonight is typically a temporal lobe issue. So what are the lobes in your brain is your temporal lobe that is right behind your ears there.
And that is there indeed that is firing causing that sound.
That's why there's no easy fix for tonight is usually.
It is really trying to work on fiery the temporal lobe. Now there are some brain based therapies that can help with that.
We used to do a lot of brain based therapy. I'm trained as a functional neurologist to these have it done that for a long time.
We do have some brain cancer patients that I still do some brain based therapy, but nothing like we used to.
The temporal lobe stimulation may be able to help tonight is.
And I can try to make a blog about that there are some specific temporal lobe stimulation techniques that may be able to help personally I never, you know, saw a lot of patients with tonight is so I don't have a lot of experience as far as how well it didn't have any of that would work.
Would sauna be helpful for tonight is I would certainly think so because if there is detoxification that needs to take place that's going to help I would think that that would be beneficial.
Just read your live email about misdiagnosis towards psych psychiatric issues with the right protocols for depression or protocols for live disease work better for teenagers.
We need, would they work better for teenagers than for adults or would they work better for teenagers.
For a live disease that's something else.
I don't know, but let me just.
So, you know, live disease can cause is one one thing that can cause inflammation of the brain that can damage microglial cells.
If you want more information about microglial damage.
If you want a great inflammation, I'd highly suggest you watch my video, let me just pull it up real quick and share it because this can be very beneficial for people that are struggling with that.
You can get to it and I'll share the blog post with the brain inflammation in the brain can cause damage to microglial cells.
And the microglial cells are a certain type of brain cell that are called that are in the class of glial cells and these glial cells these microglial cells can get what's called become become primed.
The microglial cells damage the, our damage the ability of the glial cell to be able to perform its function and the glial microglial cells function is to.
So, if you search for this on the this little thing neuro inflammation or microglial primed I have a video about microglial primed on that goal to.
It does you a detail of that for 20 minutes and explain what some what a person should do if that microglial primed for any reason whether it's due to a long standing live disease and all the research on this has actually come from post compressive syndrome research so they found that.
Post serious concussion or post multiple less serious concussions even decades later can cause microglial primed because the neuro inflammation continues to just ramp and when the microglial cells become primed and they become less active they become less able to do their job and microglial cells literally are the immune system of the brain.
They're like macrophages in the regular tissue that's what microglial cells do.
And that can end up with a lot of depression anxiety other psychiatric conditions that are diagnosed as different conditions and it all stems back to microglial primed they're fighting this is the major cause of early dementia and even possible Alzheimer's.
So it's just another theory and Alzheimer's and what can cause the placket in the.
And the tau formation of Alzheimer's disease so watch that video that will help with that the right machine can be helpful right protocols for depression can be helpful for those with depression and anxiety.
And no matter what your issues are those depression protocols can be very beneficial and definitely the live disease protocols can be very beneficial for live disease but when caveat to that is that they do kill very quickly so you want to go slow with them.
Because the person could have a hurt cyber reaction and I do have another blog on her side very actions that explain what that is so look at that as long.
Thank you for your prayers.
So whether you have depression or anxiety or any any type of psychiatric diagnosis use the right for those things you try them can be very helpful.
I lost 10 pounds because I was having constipation issues is a really good way to put on weight.
Well, I don't really have a problem with that but the biggest way to put on weight is to is to eat carbohydrates.
So the problem is you don't want to eat a whole much simple carbohydrates because that can feed the cancer so you need more complex carbohydrates really is your solution so that is like eating potatoes and sweet potatoes and rice good whole grain rice and oats and oatmeal that's the way to do that is to try to eat some more complex carbohydrates.
I keep the tissue around the tumor alkaline well I believe so but I don't know the problem with any alkaline or acidity it's really impossible to measure because you lose we need to cut the person open and stick a pH strip in them.
If you cut the person open and stick a pH strip and you you know you changed the balloon because you added oxygen and is it a pure test while I haven't anybody offer for me to cut them open and stick pH strip in them so I don't know so but under theory yes the answer is theoretically yes and I do think that that's in place.
I think we'll quit for today. Thank you for submitting your questions on the member site and and thank you for participating hopefully this is educational for everybody and know that I'll be prayed for all of you as well.